> BN
TONIGHR HINGE ANSHOWS TOIG RARR
THERE'S  OF  NOSTRIL WILL NOT ME
SIDE OF MY FACE.
R HOTEZ,HE BAYLOR HOTEZ,M ADRE.
FOE, THEY HAVE NEVERHEARD OF TH
WHAT -- WHAT IS ?
>> WELL,OU KNOW, HE IS SHOWINGSE
COMMONSEAT IS WHAT I
CALLED BELLS PSY
INFECTION.ONMSSYNDROME, WHICH I
RAL ACLY R OF CHICKENPOX VIRUS A
BUT IN SOME CASES,
AND BE ASSL
AIN, AND T
THAT IS FOLLOWA RASH, KE EAR, AF
V
COURTHE RESOLUTI
GREAT.
NPOX
ES THAT YOU MIGHT SEE WION'TVE H
SEE THI0 TO.I IT'O RECOV
THE Y YOU ARE TO HAVE  RECOVERPL
DO OKA IT BUT IT COULD
TA SOME >> AND I SHOULD NOTE YO
YOOVIDERONDER ABOU --
THBE WEL
E ITUED MYBOUT C OTH
ILLNESSES.
NCHZS BETWEE Y AIDEA OF RAMSEY
TO,BE
WHES
AND THE TWN LOOK SIMAR,
ANMETIMES IT PRENT
ILEMMA.
UAH BELLPA.
90% OF C R
AND  AHE
- PAIN AND NOCIATEDHA
SOATOU J-- LOOKING AT HIS
I GUESS  IS
, HEH EYIS DAREA
WHOLOGIS OTHER TYPE OF MAYBEN
IS -- WHO FEELS COMFORBL
ARE SEEING VESICLES
IN THE E
READ THE TEA LEAVEDEURSE.  LHOWH
ISS IT
HE
IS IT TAKINGAND HAVIT??
L, THERE ARE A FEW T
Y HUNTS LYA VATION
CHNP
SODRUG,
WH I
-- OFRTCEMES STEROIDS CAN  T